hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to don't starve
together hi Bob hey how's it going uh
pretty good I guess I did know wasn't
sure if you were asking me or the people
out there but there I imagine they're
all doing wonderful even though I hate
this intro can we do this again no you
got to use that one I think the magic of
editing can allow me to do anything I
want I mean I could I could just start
over no I'm pretty sure you tease that
one okay all right okay so we're back
and we got a science machine um we're
gonna be any be fallows no I have not
cuz I need some turds uh that's right we
need a lot of poop ah that'll probably
be the next out of poop that'll be the
next like area that we go to do you
follow the road to the graveyard to find
this yeah that that's about where it all
is okay I'm just gonna start planting
trees the mapping you discovered yeah
you should probably plant some tree I am
chopping the [ __ ] out of this forest
here we are gonna get destroyed by who
tree gods don't you remember that oh
yeah oh yeah we entered the tree gods
cuz he took too many trees and then like
accidentally lit it on fire we were just
like haha dying tree God I uh
I vaguely remember something like that
happening but if anybody's gonna anger
the tree God you know it's gonna be me
also I didn't realize its planting trees
raises your sanity oh that's nice
that's that's lovely Gumi you don't oh
yeah you log to think about that okay
where are you right now I am to the
south east uh I'm almost straight south
from camp but I sort of went south west
and then southeast and wiggled my way
through stuff
okay I'm going strike I'm trying to find
Beefalo so I can get a small a basic
farm so guarded so we can start to have
some food supply at our base instead
having a scavenger that would be a good
idea that's what I write ideas so I'm
gonna I'm gonna just try to find more
stone things to carve through so that we
have a big stockpile and then I'm gonna
build like a storage chests stuff like
that and your home so we got good things
I was like that stuff like dang well man
difference table I'm talking like that
that's how you talk
so that's how I talk when I'm normal you
know when I'm not recording it's like a
different person
hanging out with March I will see you in
the next video bye bye
oh thank God that videos over dialed up
change that right don't anybody hurts my
mind it's like normal Allah lime I don't
think they would accept me I guess you'd
have to say words it's just the cadence
hey get that Evan oh I don't know
scatter so slickers ask a man skip back
dad I love you but uh but uh but man
I've something so far away from home man
yeah good night time I think you're fine
to get the evenings are like incredibly
long for some reason I have no idea one
so did you find Beefalo yet though I did
not I didn't find any and there's an ass
load of rocks everywhere and lots of
gold which is usually a problem yeah
what no beef beef beef beef hmm let me
try to mine one of these petrified trees
no beef a leaf oh that's weird
the petrified trees you can pick ax em
into rocks so I guess that's kind of
nice we are you in the blackened area no
I'm sort of in the patchwork area right
in the middle of the map right now
coming back north uh I'm oh you're
coming north oh [ __ ] I'm going south I
mean in a Birchwood area oh are you for
you must be further west than me I'm
like maybe just barely west of camp and
like half the map south from it right
now I'm just kind of on the road going
south oh hey I'm at camp now oh geez I'm
so far south okay I think I'm gonna make
it back in time but I think uh I think
for tomorrow we should definitely move
camp down south because it seems like
there's a lot of potential down here so
we can let your Drake down the sciency
science man right can you I have no idea
um I'm gonna make a campfire for the
night that's a good move
you should do that I should build the
shovel and dig up all these graves you
absolutely probably should maybe do that
yeah use a science machine to deaf build
a prototype for a goddamn shovel what am
i stupid well we were actually just
talking about that all right come on
come on now don't be late sorry sorry
sorry sorry sorry sorry sorry what sorry
sorry sorry sorry sir sorry
you're an idiot hmm no thank you how are
you rolling
that's the a pretty close enough I guess
all right sorry sorry sorry suck ass
suck ass I'm not proper in sulfur sorry
yeah yeah sorry you're such a suck ass
suck ass yeah yes suck ass Biba
apparently my my guy doesn't trust all
this science stuff what else can i proto
tights
too bad you're such a suck ass prototype
a shovel did you just call me a suck ass
butt yeah well I don't know am I talking
to a suck ass no one calls me a suck-ass
suck ass oh I should have been eating
this whole time I am actually do you
have food I have one coke morsel right
now what do you do though your traps
only one they're not catching [ __ ] man
ah man okay how do we break down this
thing here uh oh god I love good holy
[ __ ] [ __ ] man why I had the torch out
oh I didn't mean to do that we have to
worry about breaking down the science
machine now okay good when I gather up
my completely useless traps and then
we're gonna head south hell yeah hell
yeah I can't believe that thing just
spontaneously combusted like that that's
so weird right yeah with nobody doing
anything they caused it to happen like
had that had habit oh my god now there's
just a science machine shell it's
unspeakably burnt
it's unspeakably burnt oh god remember
when we had that nice farm and then
there's everything and everything I
destroyed by it was it
lightning strike oh yeah I think it is
it wasn't because you were the robot and
you got struck by lightning oh yeah
there was another time that happened
because one of us was will oh I can't
remember who you use me I can't remember
exactly who let me let me dig up some of
these graves first maybe there's some
goodies around here ooh gems holy [ __ ]
look at all these gems yeah I'm just
gonna take these Thank You Diana
I'll get the sanity hit you take the Dan
gems i am pi of em total emptiness a
beaten beater okay that's the last of
the graves yeah I'm doing fine on sanity
slay insane perfectly fine on sanity I'm
like a full hundred percent sane right
now nice cuz you're not afraid of the
dark
I just some vegan babies okay there's
the I if I chop down these birch trees
they give birch nuts and they'll give me
those nuts okay let me I'll get you your
uh nuts you're gonna love my nuts
those birch nuts hell yeah you like
those nuts yeah I like nuts they're not
dropping nuts
oh there's one there's some nuts not all
nuts oh my god I only got three nuts
well beggars can't be choosers
but another nut there I'll be picking up
the lock oops yeah get that nut logs
what woody logs well I need logs alright
mr. Locke emic LUN Locke lunch
hey even more logs for some reason I got
a gun that was your [ __ ] log meter go
down it goes down real quick well then
again I chop quick so it's a even trade
question mark oh here's the carrot
alright okay I believe if we keep going
farther south after this pit stop we
should be able to find some beef Lou I I
went a little bit west back to the road
and I'm going south on the road okay I
have no basis to make that assumption on
about the building definitely be befell
a hundred percent there's no way there
would be what is a clockwork night and
why is it following oh yeah that guy
he's not friendly no he doesn't seem
friendly yeah he's the opposite of that
thing yeah he he wants to murder you
it certainly seems that way I'm gonna
keep following the road
it turns west yeah I'm gonna keep
following the road
are you coming I'm coming I'm coming
where are you I don't see your symbol
anymore
ah there you are whoa what is that walk
to statue what is that hand flute you
like my flute baby wow that's hot
do you like that I mean I'm the only man
in the area so own me oh well hey Bobby
boy hey there's lots of berries oh
here's a whole ass load of berries yeah
noise no oh there's cat Coons over here
are they are they neutral are they okay
I do not know I'm gonna drop this pan
flute cuz who knows what that's for what
you don't want to become a master pen
pen Flo God we spawned a turkey it's
gonna eat all our berries no [ __ ] you -
[ __ ] you eat [ __ ] turkey I'm gonna buy
berries I totally got him nice totally
got him
my turkey up okay where's the goddamn
Beefalo we've made a horrible error
Oh what the [ __ ] is that what is
happening right now something's off a
boot that rocky Oh I'm Canadian
oh yeah cuz Lumberjacks are Canadian
what the [ __ ] it is interesting Hey look
they farming carrots maybe they won't
mind if we take him Seth Rogen is
stealing our Karen oh god I can't wait
separate organization
oh god I can't laugh like him anymore
I'm starting to laugh like a Krusty the
Klown from Simpsons exactly how Seth
Rogen laughs exactly
oh my god you think that have you ever
seen them in the same place at the same
time I mean no I haven't a whole thing
they're totally the same person Jesus
how did nobody make that connection
before okay I was promised Beefalo
pretty explicitly we're not the days not
over yet
so you just calm your tips millimeters
from nighttime mom your dad's we're fine
look my tits are perfectly oh my god
what is feeling that thing killing this
thing [ __ ] christ man now it's tough
there we go killed it Wow I got yummy
I'm gonna gonna get that sale I guess
yeah you can all tail I'm a makeup buyer
of yours make fire BAM make the fire all
right I proved a misfire who provides
when you make a permanent fire cuz I had
rocks okay we're staying here perfect
well we're not but I'm just saying look
you know I just want you to have
something nice I appreciate it but I'm
just saying I don't know if this is the
spot yet like you know don't know the
house before we decide where we want the
house to be but it's like you know it's
like gestures should be appreciated
whether or not they're like right time
or something this was a really like I
really tried here it's not and I did I
said I appreciate it I do appreciate
it's not about the timing it's it's just
like you know I don't know if this is
this is like a waste of resources right
like you know I don't want to I don't
want to have to make another fire like
30 feet away from here just because this
isn't the fire that we want our kids to
grow up in well okay like I do i what I
appreciate it wait come back don't go
off to the dark okay all right I was
just getting a mushroom I was just
getting a mushroom I'm listening I'm
listening
I appreciate you thank you that's why I
sound like that
huh out of me appreciating you so I've
got some bad news
I'm about to go crazy apparently um go
pick some flowers or something I'm gonna
chop some trees and then plant some
trees cuz I have an ass load of food now
no I got food foods not gonna make me
any better
oh yeah yeah oh jeez I've seen shadows
you can do it I don't think this is
helping I'm gonna go
what the [ __ ] worth the southern tip of
okay we gotta go west
we're gonna continue exploring for the
beef alone wait Wes just is like this
water
oh is it yeah so we gotta go east but
east the water the water goes up but how
far up all right all right that's your
house your craziness there crazy pants
oh whoops
uh it's it's okay don't don't eat the
don't eat the nuts I'm gonna I'm gonna
take the nuts yeah just give me the nuts
cuz I need to plant him to up my sanity
like a lot you can plant my nuts
wherever you like oh the piggies are
outside now ow
what that shadow is actually hurting me
like legitimate oh I see you getting
hurt by a shadow what all right those
are the birch tree God all right so your
axe is over here Jesus criminy here here
here say hey okay those shadows no come
here come here I got you I got a goodies
Flint Flint your [ __ ] oh Jesus I'm too
burdened I've got why do I have this
beater
all right go play of [ __ ] play okay but
your kid got it gonna plant got a plant
planters got a plant I'm gonna pick some
flowers too all feeling better well I'm
not feeling good little boy still are
you still a crazy pants yep very crazy
take all of those [ __ ] yeah
that's good yeah I can't pick up your
axle it didn't like you it's a gross
how's your sanity their breath bad pick
all the flowers you could trying Jesus
pick pick'em i need a flower crown
that's what I need I need a oh you must
have an ass load of petals by now how do
we make a I've only got seven I don't
have enough gnarley' here I've got I've
got three let me give my three to you
okay good there you what alright that
you need one more flower petal and well
a shadow where's my those are seeds
where the [ __ ] is my flower petal sit
there okay hang on I got a I'm dodging
this thing that you can't see okay
that's enough
oh no we can fly around make okay get me
[ __ ] making it how much I get like we're
in it you okay and Sandy's going up
still got a crazy day after me but we're
doing okay let's go let's run away from
the crazy thing towards the Northeast
Jim my problem was that I also ate some
mushrooms and those didn't do me too
good
so that was bad something about those
mushrooms was a mistake Sears we passed
all this already haven't we yeah we did
check pressing him to check your map
yeah yeah
we just need to explore to the east and
then the south okay the road led us to a
dead end
okay yeah I think so alright see also
dead end yeah this is just a pig Ninh
Silla a pig nintzel a--that's a good
term for it I like that ah why are you
saying uh there's a monster after me a
shadow monster how how sane do you have
to get I'm at 98 right now it's a little
above halfway there
uh the problem being it's now evening
and I'm parently going more insane by
this we should make a campfire wait
which direction do we need to go I only
need to go east from here no still kiss
that's an attacker do knock your fish up
oh [ __ ] yeah that's no good that oh it's
another Pig house oh it's a bridge to
another area this is good oh wait I'm
gonna steal their honey oh no there's
just a nasty little flowers like oh
Jesus
it's oh it's death Rosa wait I need some
flowers I got Oh run how is this big
living here let's go let's go let's go
apparently that we just need to stay out
of their air but that does connect if
you see down on the map it does connect
to some other area beyond it I think we
gotta go Dyer take a break past them
yeah I think we got a that's important
are you heading back over there now I'm
or I never left I will protect you
Oh God they only want to kill you there
oh my god oh Jesus okay oh well let's
say what was down here wasn't a lot more
bees Oh Oh bees bees Oh and Hornets I'm
good how the [ __ ] do we resurrect
ourselves we got to go all the way back
to the beginning to the touchstone oh
here is the other is more over here so
there there was a reason oh boy yeah we
got to go all the way back but we'll do
that in the next episode cuz that's that
Venus right okay so thank you everybody
so much for watching thankfully in this
particular game oh don't mind my mic we
can resurrect ourselves and we can get
back there so we'll do that before we
get back to you so thanks again
everybody for watching as always
[Music]
why are you so good at this game I'll
show you where Jackie oh yeah
right you're such a [ __ ]